i'm married and i have slumber parties
like once a week my friend came over and
it was not planned but she ended up
spending the night and we slept and
my bad and my husband slept in our guest
room
jennifer lawrence opening up about
married life on heather mcmahon's
podcast
absolutely not cook and i tried to play
tennis the other day but
i have um a temper pablo and so
we had the court for an hour and he was
like how long do you think we're gonna
make it i was like i think we can go the
whole hour i mean if we get tired maybe
30 minutes
and he was like yeah we made it 15
minutes i missed a ball
and i turned around and i chucked the
racket as far as i could
after screaming so many profanities in
front of
so many children right through the rack
at his heart hood and he
came over to be like you're right babe
and then the lower lip started trembling
and i just started falling
yeah jayla also talks about auditioning
for two major movies
easy a and twilight everybody
is always shocked when i'm like oh yeah
i auditioned for twilight oh yeah and
then i both
auditioned for eza she beat me in her
own words because
i stuck like i was an auditioning actor
like
everybody else i still have moments
where i'm like oh my god i have to go to
an
audition like we're all sitting in the
room like all staring at each other all
blondes all dressed the same
and the oscar winner gets candid about
politics too
revealing she grew up republican but has
since changed her tune
it's extremely hard to talk about
politics and that you know you don't
want to
it's right i'm an actor i want everybody
to see my movies
i grew up republican the first president
my first time voting i voted for john
mccain
for me when donald trump got elected
that just changed everything
because i you know this is an impeached
president who's broken
many laws and has refused to condemn
white supremacy and a few other fun
facts you learned about jennifer
she's been watching below deck sailing
yacht during quarantine
she claims to be extremely frugal and
get this
her favorite housewife is lisa rinna
honestly lisa renna because i'm just
like bless her heart like she
just can't she she can't control her
mouth which i of course
relate to